I'm a basketball player never golf today
in my life I'm about to learn lessons
from a pro number 26 caliber in the
world
Xander souffle I'm nervous since he's
never gripped or even swung a golf club
you guys failed to mention that to me
what I thought different about coming
out I'm just kidding
my Diaz family definitely hooked it up I
never knew golf gear was just
comfortable it's pretty hot but with the
shirt on I feel pretty cool out here
so bro are you I'm excited your
brother's doing alright
basics usually you try to stand like
shoulder-width open that up a little bit
grip is easy no other way so there you
go
you come up to the top what I think of
this I try to put my lower body move in
and then everything kind of follows so
I'm on a lot of time everyone clear out
you look bad now there you go
oh man this shirt is so silky smooth bro
shot about two three strides SPF exactly
man no sweat all right so driver you're
gonna stay a little further away okay Oh
ball this is con well you look like when
you're swinging Cal looking like this
one here really quick versus it's sort
of like a really slow you can't like sit
back into it uh-huh it feels really slow
yeah exactly and then another one one
time I can make you step over there way
[Music]
up in the air so you sort of put up on
your stance you can kind of lean Hopa
now I'm going to show you how it's done
oh my god obviously my technique isn't
where it needs to be right now but with
the proper instructions from the vendor
I can get better but it didn't feel as
good as when I saw him hit the ball
seventy five thousand feet that's the
best one I'm thinking God oh oh sir
yelling at me if people can hit in LA
more man they're being mean and
comparing us yeah the fact that you're
hitting this out there already is yes is
incredible you know you have your own
style your own swag with it a lot like
help to knives Wendy well I'm your
biggest fan yeah yeah we should have a
brother yeah